3 du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
la parole est à mme losier geoffroy
merci monsieur le président c'est le
ministre nos forces de police et de
gendarmerie n'en peuvent plus elles sont
éreintés par les charges qui pèsent sur
elle et par les événements si lourd qui
les contraignent à une activité
surdimensionné et je tiens ici au nom de
beaucoup est probablement la totalité
d'entre nous alors dire une fois de plus
qu'elle est notre soutien et combien
nous admirons leurs efforts
monsieur le premier ministre
à chaque fois que nous souhaitons vous
parler de ce sujet vous et votre
ministre de l'intérieur n'avait de cesse
de nous renvoyer les mêmes arguments les
mêmes chiffres comme si l'air martial
c'est vous perdez cotler la colère
feinte suffisait à tordre la vérité des
chiffres la vérité des chiffres quelle
est elle elle est celle qui est donnée
par la cour des comptes 2001 dernières
années du gouvernement jospin deux cent
quarante mille deux cents un policier
gendarme 2011 dernières années du
gouvernement fillon
241/1000
0,34 2014 troisième année du
gouvernement sous la présidence hollande
1245 c'est la réalité des chiffres et
sur la période 2012 2015 alors que vous
nous aviez promis 9000 emplois créés sur
la législature plus 390 si on ajoute ça
c'est plus 390 les plus
2286 promis pour 2017 vous ne serez pas
à l'issue de cette législature au tiers
de ce sur quoi vous vous êtes engagé
monsieur le premier ministre
[Musique]
quand allez-vous passer aux actes et
cesser de parler de chiffres qui ne
veulent rien dire quand allez-vous en
particulier à propos de la loi sur la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence enfin
donné satisfaction aux hommes eng
légitimes de nos forces de police et de
gendarmerie
monsieur geoffroy à la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre manuel
valls
seul président
monsieur guy geoffroy mais
j'ai pas envie de polémiquer avec vous
pourquoi ici en europe polémiquer je
vous connais bien et avec ce ton sur la
question des forces de sécurité
le ministre de l'intérieur dans le cadre
du débat budgétaire a déjà eu l'occasion
d'y revenir et tout simplement de
rappeler un chiffre dans le débat que
nous avons aujourd'hui en 2017 soyons
précis la gendarmerie va bénéficier de 2
155 création d'effectifs après 2443
création en 2016 ce sont deux mille
trente et une création nette qui seront
effectués dans la police nationale dont
mille sept cent trente et une au titre
du plan antiterroriste et du pacte de
sécurité
ce sont ces chiffres lors vous découpez
vous rappelez vous tordez les chiffres
de la cour des comptes très bien mais il
y a comme le rappelait bernard cazeneuve
guerre des chiffres implacables qui ont
été rappelés les treize mille
suppressions de postes entre 2007 et
2012 et la création de 9000 oppose s'il
vous plaît entre 2012 et 2017 mais on
peut continuer ainsi à se renvoyer les
chiffres les uns et les autres ce que je
sais monsieur geoffroy c1 comme vous
l'avez fait vous avez bien raison il
faut rendre hommage d'abord aux forces
de l'ordre aux forces de sécurité à nos
gendarmes à nos policiers et à nos
policiers municipaux pour le travail qui
est engagée à la fois pour protéger les
français lutter contre la délinquance et
lutter contre le terrorisme la deuxième
chose que nous savons c'est qu'il faut
accroître les moyens à la fois les
postes créés
les éléments de protection pour nos
forces de l'ordre les investissements
pour les commissariats les hôtels de
police comme les brigades de gendarmerie
les armes les véhicules les gilets pare
balles pour évidemment les protéger et
puis nous savons enfin une troisième
chose c'est qu'il faudra continuer cet
effort cet effort il est vrai il faudra
le poursuivre en matière de défense de
justice et aussi pour le ministère de
l'intérieur et - monsieur geoffroy je ne
sais pas comment on réussit à augmenter
les moyens dans les années qui viennent
en annonçant qu'on vous supprimez par
ailleurs 300 milles à 700 mille postes
de fonctionnaires sur l'ensemble des
fonctions publiques donc je vous renvoie
à votre cohérence nous nous sommes
cohérents nous avions dénoncé les
suppressions de postes nous en créons et
nous continuons à ancrer parce qu'il en
va de la protection des français